running
we had very straining a very troubling
incident just after noon here in
Manhattan helicopter crash
I want to say the most important thing
first there is no indication at this
time that this was an act of terror
and there is no ongoing threat
based on all the information we have
right now
I checked in with Fire Department police
department and Buildings Department
there is no danger of any kind to New
Yorkers at this point
and what I'm going to tell you what my
colleagues going to tell you is all
preliminary information I'm going to
emphasize to everyone a full
investigation is going on we have only
preliminary information at this point
time but what we do know is that one
person died in this helicopter crash
that person is presumed to be the pilot
but we're still waiting for absolute
confirmation of fact there does not
appear to have been any passenger in the
helicopter but again we'll wait for
absolute confirmation that fact
we do not know the cause of this
incident I'm sure you're going to all
want to ask that we do not know the
purpose but again we have no indication
that there was any terror Nexus here
there were no other injuries that we
know of at this point in time to anyone
in the building or on the ground and I
wanted to say thank God for that this
could have been much more skin said
thank God no other people were injured
in this absolutely shocking stunning
incident
I want to lastly say that the first
responders perform it perform an
extraordinary effort here I want to
thank the part of our Police Department
everyone all the Buildings Department
all the agencies that responded hero
a.m. everybody this was very talented
situation and
from the Commissioner of fire on the
roof that had to be dealt with
immediately at the end why did an
exceptional job and addressing the
situation and ensuring that everyone
would be safe with that I want to turn
to our fire commissioners and I go
I said 143 this afternoon
we received a call nine-one-one this
helicopter had crashed on the roof
members are units local units responded
four minutes members of the fire
department that was in police department
made their way to the roof
the fire quite quickly
but fortunately we did find a big
dr. who was the mayor stated we presumed
was the pilot but is the only victim of
this crash the fire has been
extinguished there was a some about a
Fuli
safe
building management
a Nazi
boys professor Jimmy O'Neill
thanks mr. mayor so 1:43 afternoon the
first time when one close came and
reported crash the fire in top 787's
evidently was read across the street
that's a good before story office
building which personnel responded as
Dan said Nigro said great quickly FDNY
personnel put out the fire at this point
we have one confirmed fatality in an
individual as Dan said is believed to be
the pilot of a privately owned
helicopter what we know is that
approximately 1:30 2:00 this afternoon
the helicopter took off from the 34th
Street heliport at about 11 minutes
later perished on the roof across the
street from where we are now right now
our detective bureau Intelligence Bureau
of the FBI working with the FAA and the
NTSB you have the additional info on the
tentacley identified the aircraft the
flight path and its own going out to
much more as we said that's luminary but
at this point thanks for question taken
from the Josh wrote on Josh
Yeah right and tentatively we have it as
an executive travel yes
now we don't think it was going back to
the top airport head to New Jersey
preliminary
not sure if that's smart the
investigation
it doesn't appear to be the owner we
have him preliminary identify but it's
not confirmed yet and of course
hangout for his family too
that's part of the investigation to see
if there was any contact made with the
air traffic control
hold on hold on back there
then is it is it TF or there that's my
temporary flight restriction and we're a
technical checking into that Namco and
to be clear just a touch this event to
go into that area the helicopter would
need the approval of LaGuardia Tower and
we need to find out if that happened or
not here we do not know it
we got some cool - a setback on the
building
well that what a good time all that
I just want to start read the
firefighters have to deal with a fire
tell about the 50th story we
extraordinary difficult under any
circumstance and in the middle of this
weather
so FDNY did an extraordinary job hey Dan
quickly getting up there using the
building elevators pumping water over
700
wires special always special popplers
which we have available they would put
to good use today and the members got
those nines as quickly as possible to
that room and put this fire out
ooh is there anything I know that
say that again
and that's been our way to we don't know
that Henry weed Henry we don't know
that's what we're trying to confirm if
they had any contact with the partying
tower or any other
right now as we get updates we'll make
them available thank you very much
everyone
drink is ready from the ball case you
ready to go